women's rights around the world have
come a long way in the past 20 years but
there's still a hell of a way to go boys
and girls are enrolling in primary
school at the same rate almost
everywhere and in wealthier countries
women outnumber men in universities but
women still make up two-thirds of the
world's illiterate and in the workforce
there has been little improvement in
women's participation and in closing the
gender pay gap globally only fifty-five
percent of women compared to eighty-two
percent of men work they also earn
between ten and forty percent less than
men in the US women spend twice as much
time on unpaid work as men do and at the
very top women CEOs running Fortune 500
companies went from zero to just five
percent in the past twenty years talk
about a glass ceiling
you